muhammad azlam is a danish citizen he
came to copenhagen from pakistan as a
seven-year-old his children were born
here in the myanaparkan district
but a drive to abolish so-called ghettos
has led to the danish government
reclassifying citizens along racial
lines
with the azlam family now labeled icca
vesliger
non-western
if you are lived in the western western
county then you have the full right
and if you are lived in the non-western
country then you don't have the same
right it's very terrible to think about
we can make such kind of law in denmark
in my country
it could be seen as a laudable goal
aiming for greater racial integration
and reduced crime but the problem is how
the government plans to do it setting
ethnic quotas for every district in the
country
it's part of a raft of measures the
government has brought in to abolish
ghettos within the next decade
by then the aim is for every district in
the country to have a population that is
at least 70 percent western
80 percent of milner parkan's residents
are from an immigrant background the
danish government can't make people
leave areas like milner park and purely
on the basis of ethnicity what it can do
is force the housing to be sold off to
private investors who then raise the
rents
the idea is that mainly western people
assumed to be more wealthy will then be
able to move back in but the laws
regarding ghettos go further they
include lower welfare payments for
people moving into areas on the
government's ghetto list
and harsher punishments for criminals in
ghetto areas
also a ban on refugees moving into the
targeted districts
residents are suing the government
an anti-segregation policy centered on
social conditions and crime rates would
be valid but we object to removing
people from their homes based on
ethnicity they've been positive
development in these residential areas
but the measures against them have got
more and more intense
minorities find themselves stuck they
move out of one area to lower the number
of non-westerners but can't move into
another area for the same reason
the government declined our requests for
an interview or a statement but as it
pushes ahead with the controversial
ghetto laws many people still don't know
where they will be housed or where they
will be welcome will it be safe for us
and our kids and our generation
to live in denmark in the in the future
you know
and wait anxiously to see if their
voices will count for anything in the
country they always thought of as home
paul reese al jazeera copenhagen